okay hello everybody and welcome to my
talk on using Conan in the real world
complex project my name is Gaston yep I
shall I have experienced from working in
converge
a key tallest and include OS and my
background is a primarily programmer but
I also worked on a lot of build systems
during that time it's a little
background for this I was hired to port
included us from x86 is to 460 for tolls
run on our 64 architectures after NDC
last year kind of convenient include us
is an open source modern C++ library
operating system for those who don't
know that and it went bankrupt in June
this year so kind of sad story but it's
open source so please contribute to keep
it alive if you have the option to do so
so I'll be presenting here today is why
we introduced the package manager in
include OS :
and some basic features in common common
inside include OS and hopefully some
demos actually there will likely be a
quite a lot of and some tips and tricks
of based on our experience working with
common in so let's start why
introduce a package manager and include
OS software my question why would you do
anything with something that's already
there so basically I would go through
what we had in include OS which was we
had dependencies built outside the CI
system so we can start there everybody
sit anyone seen stuff like that before
we had some git submodules I don't know
if you guys like them I prefer I don't
prefer them at all lots of complex C
make for handling these dependencies and
pulling in things some environment
variables were needed to get things put
into play
operating system-level lots of bash
scripts to install things and move
things around and compile some of the
dependencies but not all of them didn't
always work it couldn't build out of
tree because it had dependencies
internally and even sometimes when you
built it it would fail if you had a fast
enough computer so that's why I say what
changes is it work right well there are
quite a few reasons why you would want
to change this we needed to port against
across architectures so if you look at
the above list imagine walking through
all of that and trying to add another
architecture to it and make it stable
you introduced a lot of complexity to it
you also have the maintainability of
what you have as I said the above was
already complex and you need to look at
can you make it any better
and also it wasn't reliable so you could
build it it would fail and then you
tried three four times and then it will
work reason being quite simple when you
do the sea makes external project thing
it'll pull something down compile time
and if you link to that you'll get a
timing issue and it doesn't really work
well so that was a lot of the reasoning
why we wanted to change it and also to
improve user experience which is mainly
I think the biggest value of changing to
: so why common well I had a lot of
different options I'm not going to go
through them probably more than those
I'm not an expert on any of them I can
say that straight out but we did take a
few things into consideration looking at
what we needed was some kind of
artifactory ben tre's sort of
integration we wanted something with
good traction having a close
relationship with the a-goin : we sort
of had the know-how of words go
and what they're working on and we can
monitor the project see make was
important for us cuz we already had tons
of CMake and if it doesn't integrate
well that you're basically starting with
something new and also history wise
what's the history of this package
manager' and in Conan's case it's sort
of a started off as an open source but
they were bought in by the Jay Frog
teams or in that sphere working with
artifactory and sort of like integrated
and also the community around it they
have the wrong channel on CPP Lang slack
and you can discuss with them get help
and they're also all the channels using
them so that's important as well
ah and as I said it's obvious we went
from Conan based on the talk here but
there might be others that can do the
same so let's start with Conan what is
common
they said themselves it's a binary C++
package manager what does that mean
anybody want to try to give it a clue of
what that actually means yeah that's one
way of interpreting it yeah so they're
also claimed this is their statement the
open source decentralized multi-platform
package manager to create and share your
native binaries there are a few things
there that I picked up on is that well
this is incorrect and a few other things
as well
it doesn't need to be limited to
compiled C++ code either I would maybe
phrase it something like this after
working with it for six seven months an
open source decentralized way to build
distribute and consume binary packages
and recipes across platforms because you
can cross-platform them they don't have
to be needed but that's just my
interpretation of that sentence
so getting started with Conan very
simple if you have pip you install it by
pep if you have a distribution that has
a proper package for it you can install
it that way the windows part I'm not
going to go into on this talk I'll leave
it completely out but I know it works on
Windows as well so using the Conan help
command you get this list out which the
very various commands you can use in
Conan and you've got some consumer
commands which is for the end users and
then you have the creator commands that
are for people creating conan packages
packages and then you have the tools to
work on the created packages i'm not
going to go through every single one of
them but there are quite a few you can
you normally run into and that is and
you'll run into the profile which is the
most important key in Conan which is the
mark-up of how your compiler
configuration and package configuration
is like what tooling are you building
for you have the install command as a
consumer that basically installs a list
of packages into your current directory
or wherever you want to also have the
create command which is normally used by
the CI system to create an actual
package you do want to do it internally
from time to time but it's it's mostly a
CI command you have to build you can use
and then you have the editable which I'm
going to get back to which is probably
one of the hardest things to get right
in conch
and of course you got the remotes like
pretty much like get remotes you say
where are my repositories and how am I
gonna work with it you have the search
to search you have the info to get
information about your dependencies so
it's a lot of packages a lot of clients
you can use to work on the packages from
different locations my suggestion is if
you start with this start small if you
go full out I'll take your time because
it takes some time to get to know this
so some of the control files conan uses
they have a common file pi which is
mainly for a package you want to i'll
say yeah a package you want to give out
to someone like so somebody can consume
it that's when you will write a common
file pi which is an explanation on how
you build a source code how you deploy
it and how you consume it and what
dependencies does it have everything
goes into a common file pi conan file
txt this more of a consumer level where
you say which common file packages what
which common packages am i consuming in
this project project so there are sort
of a link between these two because you
can have a project where you have both a
conan file pi and a common file txt
because you want to use that package
just as it is or you want to use that
package in another project again in
which case it's better to just go to con
file pi you have the layout text which
is for editing packages in editable mode
you have a llamó file saying what you're
allowed to say like can I use this
compiler let's say you bring down a
brand new compiler in common doesn't
really support it you can add it there
that's control parameters and get the
profiles which defines which tool chains
you're using the target architecture and
also you can define dependencies in
profile
so let's go through these so the corn
file.txt so this one is a requires is
one statement which is where you're
telling what packages are going into my
component as the sense that I'm actually
linking them into my component and build
requires our what tools do I need to
build my component and you have this
fancy syntax here take note that this
will try to use any package newer than
this version and the reason I did the
include pre-release is that semantic
versioning in Conant will not get
triggered before you reach a 1.0 unless
you put that keyword and then you have a
user and a channel we sort of like git
branch is a nice comparison to that so
you can have different branches in
common so you can have the latest branch
and then you can have a stable branch
which was we did in this case so this
package here this is from our hello
world example it says I'm gonna need
include is it's gonna be newer than this
version don't really care which one and
please pick it for him from include us
latest and not the stable and the same
with the chain over which is a tool to
boot it up but the BM Runner which is a
different tool I'm saying I want version
this fixed version into Myer consumer
being bill the same and then I have the
generators which is the virtual
environment generator and a seeming
generator which is the ones we're using
in this case that's an example on how a
coma file text can look like Conan file
PI however we start getting more
complicated that's peyten not everybody
likes Python but it's it's it's a tool
and you know start by explaining a I
have my package and I it's so classy
on the common file I said what name it
is what version it is of course you will
say a lot more but this is the minimum
you can do and then you have a function
to say I'm gonna fetch my source code a
function to say I'm going to build a
source code and a function saying I'm
gonna package this or a source code you
also a lot of other options here you
have options to sort of add additional
configuration to this but I'm not gonna
go into it right now what is important
though when you look at this is that
this looks like a class but it isn't
because Konan parses this and finds your
functions and call your functions based
on the command you give so you can't
really set a variable here and expect it
to change here so what you should the
way you should be interpret this as
three separate classes so you'll have
one where your source one way you build
and one where your package just to get
your head around that to avoid stepping
into the faults you can get and this is
taken from the Bing crafter skies
because they made this very nicely for
me so I could just use it to sort of try
to explain it but it's important to look
at it this way because you run into a
lot of faults if you try to change
variables in between these methods so
Conan file PI you can do different
things you can have a comma file PI this
one which I will open up which actually
uses this one so you can have
inheritance between them I would knock
or not recommended to start with but at
a certain point you might want to reuse
methods and and get some dry into your
common files at which point you you
would need this let me just jump around
the wet hair
so in this just get my head over head in
place give me a second yeah
so this is our include to us : file PI
this covers a lot more ground than my
very small example lid here we're using
the feature from Conan which is Python
requires we where I'm telling Conan that
I actually need this package to use this
package and it'll download this and use
it into my tooling so I can use the
conan tools get semantic versioning
which is it generated to actually just
from my current get tagged and commits
after the gate tag it generates a
semantic versioning number which is
convenient to avoid having to type it in
every time so you can leave the common
files untouched once you have them right
cover your license
the generators he make in virtual and
URL and then you got this particle SEM
which I'm telling Conan that this is get
so when I build I want you to fill out
whatever get tagged I'm building from
and and although the remotes etc so I
didn't reproduced later then we have
another field here called options
options are away in Conan to have
alternate behavior on a package options
to let's say leave out OpenSSL include
this you can serve like you get around
going from C C++ perspective and
packages in general that you control
them with options Conan does require you
to put a default options so that the
platform in include us is default SMP is
default off another basic options then
it got the no copy source true where
you're telling Conan that we're actually
not going to copy all the source code
because we were doing see make so we're
building out of trees so it doesn't make
sense to copy the source code wrong then
we go into requirements which is the
same as the requires part of the con
file text in behavior where I'm telling
that I need GSL because we're using GSL
if we are in user space we're basically
building native application we don't
need to build in our custom-built cxx
libraries if it's our v8
I need this additional package if the
platform is not no no I also need these
tools into my system these libraries
into into the system if I'm building
with the solo 5-htt so 5-htt is a IBM's
version of firecracker basically it's a
super small virtual machine
I'll run isolate by itself with the
minimum API you can do and it needs to
run with GCC because the IBM guy says
don't use anything else so if your
compiler is not GCC then you get an
invalid configuration warning from Colin
which is why I included the invalid
configuration part here from Conan also
I included piping requires as I needed
here see make as I'm using further down
and Conan file is of course always
needed then you got the configure part
which we it's the next part here so got
the first you got the requirements which
is get your cars parked right configure
is run like prior to building is sort of
part of getting your getting your
checksum calculated so I'm saying that
do all of this but actually exclude
which 6x compiler know which is the
exact library I'm using so that's will
not be part of my check something and
you can do all of this magic but it's
really hard to get it right
so start by doing something simple and
then go on then you got the target
architecture you can go through you can
define your own functions because the
functions will be in class level but the
common functions that Konan are
searching for inside methods those are
the functional parts so you get the
build step because we got the source
already that's the SM the build step
will run the configure C make that we'll
use the options I put in to get some C
make variables set right and then return
the C make where I call C make build and
as you see here once I get to the
package step I have to do it again
because of the functional thing there is
nothing left in between and then I run C
make install at the package step you can
also manually copy every single dot a
file where you want every single dot H
file where you want but fixtures C make
install that's a lot easier and then you
got the package info which is a bit
hacky some places but it's fine this one
it's quite self-explanatory I did this
trick to get the C make part of my
package available for the consumer I'm
adding my include directories to say
this is going to be available for you
which is outside because the fault is
lip is available include is available
but if you have something outside of
that scope you should added in here to
make sure the consumer can consume it it
also affects how the generators will
generate CMA code and all of that and
then we got some more Python magic here
to get the rights library names out so
when you consume it you say hey this is
my architecture and they did a library
name based on the architecture probably
a bad design but we didn't want to
change it
then you got some with the CVP info lips
I'm telling which libraries which
libraries in this package are you going
to consume if you use my package and I'm
also telling where where are these
packages because they can be in two
different structures so you kind of
explaining like this is how my package
looks like in a generic way so a
consumer can consume it and then you
have the deploy step which basically if
you do a deploy you take the conan
package and deploy it to your filesystem
in a given structure this is nice if you
want to generate another type of package
let's say you want to put it inside the
debian package or whatever you can use
this it's a feature so those are quite
short but intensive round of the cone
file PI not sure if you got anything out
of it but hopefully you did so let's get
back to our slides here yeah of course
you couldn't figure out what was up next
time yeah I need to fix my presentation
inside
this is gonna take a while sorry for
that yes we were there that took forever
slide 12 then you have the common
profile I'm not gonna just console this
time common profile for on this system
for include OS is actually I'm building
a for a Linux system or Monaco's so I'm
cross compiling my architecture is still
the same when I'm cross compiling I'm
telling which compiler I'm using the
version which Lib C++ I'm using the C++
standard I want to have and the build
type I'm also setting up my compiler
optimizations and all that in my profile
which is one way of doing it and I'm
also saying that every single package
I'm building with this profile
I want my opinion tools to be available
for second so like add your global
dependency say ok you could potentially
do I've seen the examples where they do
do the whole tool chain this way so you
put the whole tool chain in this way and
just ignore it
everywhere else Conan has a lot of
generators you got C make C make multi
parts fine package yeah tons of stuff
Visual Studio X called GCC even got a
text version or an adjacent version so
if you want to take a generator and fix
it into your custom system you can
actually just create that in column
but in the included eyes we only use C
make a virtual environment pretty much
enough and that's for now might change
in the future
yeah so when you start working with
Conan the first thing you do is you add
some repositories you need we have the
bin tray repository yeah this one is the
wrong copy no it's not we have the
include OS repo on bin tray and you have
a common repo on Ben grey so this is our
custom packages and this is external
packages for in our case of course if
you're running this in a closed
environment you need to fix this
yourself
fortunately coming : actually has an
internal server you can run up so you
don't have to necessarily install a
factory you can actually just run that
server but if you want to investigate
and work with it you should probably
install it
yeah : see make a separate tool back
home right it allows you to wrap common
commands inside of CMake we started off
by doing it and went away from it
because of a usability point of view but
as you start if you already have a see
make project you might want to use this
just to get that one package in and get
started working on it as you can see
here you can you can directly quote
which package you want to include or you
can have a common file and have it
included all those packages for you both
are equally valuable so let's go over to
include OS get some heavy stuff here
coming I think no basically as I said we
had a binary bundle built outside the CI
system initially so as a proof of
concept we took that binary blob and
replaced it with a common package it's
essentially still the same Bob we just
put it inside a common package so we
replaced the semi external project with
his colon Simic run command and that was
it what happened was that by doing this
when we run the seam a command the
dependencies downloaded at configured
time as opposed to see make external
project where it actually gets run in as
you're running it and the real work was
to create common packages for all these
dependencies the rapid Jason GSL HTTP
parser some of these are header only
dependencies you might say it's a bit of
a stretch to put that into a package but
it's kind of convenient because then you
actually know which version you are
consuming and get all the traction or in
order
the hardest ones here are probably like
muscle and Lipsy and all of these to get
them right also we went into the unit
testing and created cone file.txt for
what are the dependencies for the unit
testing and our dependencies for the
unit testing once we get them in we
fixed all those rebuilds those were
someone who can move our unit tests
around and run the moon rep wherever we
wanted because it was isolated way
refactoring wise we moved all libraries
that weren't part of what we call the
core operating system out from the
operating system and into individual
common packages so they all got their
own cone file pi and they all got their
own versions and in addition to that we
moved all our tooling into common
packages so all our tools that were
downloaded from different locations and
compiled and installed into some prefix
and /bin or whatever all of them got
their own colon file PI and a version
number and put into the CI system at all
and the next step was we now had a
system where where we had included as
was building as a library from Conan but
it wasn't really deployed for the
consumers yet so we figured out well
let's let's use cone uninstall with a
common file text to get your included
environment in place so we by doing that
we generated common building for CMake
we added a nice based on the kind of
building for CMake we got the parts
right so we could do an include OS
inside the C make where we put all our
fancy functions that we needed and also
we added the common file text for every
single example and started using it in
our integration tests as well
and this is part of the usability factor
when it takes five minutes on a clean
system to download all your dependencies
and build and include as VM and run it
up and you also get a full dependency
graph so it's kind of a it's nice nice
feature so it's demo time get this demo
up and running so here we have our hello
world example I'm actually gonna show it
in code because it's easier to look at
so that our hello world where we have a
common file text which I showed you
earlier played a little bit around with
it doesn't really matter and we have a C
make so this is our C make for building
a virtual machine doing a hello world
and we do the operating system and
executable its to wrap the eternal
things in C make it could maybe be done
otherwise but it's kind of a convenient
way to have a slightly look and feel
like a normal executable but we're
expressing that you're doing something
else than a normal executable so this
include common building for C make will
give me all my dependencies all my
libraries and everything in order with
respect to that and Konan basic setup is
just configuring that part for me
include OS includes OS dot C make which
is a self-made file that's part of the
operating system and then you have D I
want to add this executable and I want
to add a default STD out which is a
library we have can also add additional
drivers to it but in this case we can
get away with only this
so the main for this program is very big
it's not the hardest thing to get and we
provide to the VM for it and a Jenkins
file that will actually build it so for
every release god will include us we get
a test build that yes this application
still links so in case we mess something
up which of course didn't happen let's
see if we can get it running so first
I'm gonna check if my remotes are in
order they're not know it's list sorry
so I got to include Restrepo here oh
yeah sorry that help said okay in back
so I got the include Wes repulsor or
setup in Conan here
so let's say I'm just as you saw there
it's an empty so I'll make a build
folder and then in my bail folder I will
do for remembrance I'll do Conan profile
list
just show me what profiles I have
available and here we have a profile for
Apple client 10 which is when I build
something needed to execute locally and
I have a clang 6 on the old Mac OS which
was when I want to compile something to
be run as a Linux elf and then I do
Conan install and you saw the comma file
earlier of da top which is where the
column file is and with the profile
client McCullough's
so let's scroll to this because it did a
lot and they did it fast cuz the locally
cached let's ever it goes in so it
starts by listing a this is the tools
you used and if you didn't specify
anything it will just do some guess
working this is the environment you
wanted there's a warning here that some
of the requirements are not in sync so
Connor will tell you if if you have one
package that depends on something and
another package that depends on
something and the versioning is not
correct it'll complain this is because
Kona is built for static linking so it's
kind of want to warn you that yeah you
you can't really do this it does
override it it tons of warning here in
the version range is resolved to this so
every time it needs to resolve one of
these you get a warning on it then it
goes to installing the packages this is
the requirements for include us and
their role in my cache this is summing
up the packages once more this is the
tools needed to build it and this of
course comes from my tool chain file
because I didn't specify any where I
need this but my tool chain my profile
is telling me I need this so that's why
it's pulling it in then you have cross
build so it detects item cross building
and just apply all of this so what they
did do let's get back to Adam here for a
second so in my build folder we got a
activate Sh a Conan lock a Kona build
info Topsy make a building for the text
graph info Jason so let's have a look at
this slightly fastly here it's my wife's
computer that's why her name is there
interestingly enough I don't know or I
don't ever want to own a Mac that's why
I'm just joking
and if you scroll down here is he it
generated quite a lot of sea make for me
about compilers tools everything and
they're all pointing you see it's
pointing to the directories which where
all the directories are in my cache
they're not local let's see that's yeah
got the building for text which is sort
of like a textual explanation this can
be parsed by any tool so it's easy to
work with and you got the info as well
which is like what options have been
used here to build this which is sort of
needed and then you have the activate
and deactivate that's my virtual end
generator that's generating those so in
my activate I'll get kind of nice I'll
get something added to my Python path
something added to my path and some
local variables that are defined by
packages so a package can actually say
that if you consume me then I'll set
this environment variable to this which
is a convenient way to sort of express
what you want to do so what we can do
then on a Mac is we can source activate
a sage that's what basically happened
there as I got my CC variable set right
and of course I haven't run C mate yet
so I can do this you make that up I'm
gonna run C make
so how does he make work in this case
because see make will default to try and
build an executor binary I haven't
specified the C make I'm cross-compiling
but I have specified the C make that I
don't want you to test anything other
than compiling a library so start
getting away with it without doing a
full cross compiler then you get all
these library found so it's found
operating system architecture all of
these they found all my libraries that's
good so let's see if we can build it
yeah so we built the target hello that's
nice didn't take a lot of time look at
it and the hello app is 1.4 megabytes
and then we can boot so boot is a tool
that's provided by VM runners that's now
in my path as well I can booth hello
of course needs password it's normally
the way when you run the VM the VM run
up printed hello world and exit it
yeah and me and not being too much
friends with Mac at the moment yep
that's an example of how you can build
and run the hello world example so that
morale it's not that anything
interesting so let's see if we can get
something more from this so you do a
common info on the on the package
with the right profile I think that's
the end we might just try common info
yeah it doesn't work so in the profile
here
so what I did now was it gives you all
the information on all the packages
going into this that's convenient don't
do something else with this yes of
course again we can use a generator to
generate my dependency HT you know so
you can print out but I got a HTML file
which I think I can open and do that I
put uh yeah so it generates this big
file you'd open it with something else
this the correct
no it's minus a is it yeah so it's a
nice Apple trick to get away from it so
here I have my dependencies so you see
my corn fall texted saying hey you need
these tools and then you need include OS
which needs these libraries which again
needs this and this and this and not
which is I think one of the most
powerful things in common is this is
built into it always nice to know what
you build it from yeah see if I can
return to where I am
I don't want you up there sorry about
this
not a tooling expert yeah I'm just gonna
go over for it like this so Conan
editable on the other hand so we covered
how to run up an example program covered
some of the common files going into some
of the dependencies so what about
editing a package but say I want to
change some content in one of the
packages I want to rewrite some of the
basic code how would you go about doing
that so one way it would be that I will
check out the code and get do my changes
run the unit test push it to the CI pull
it back down and then test it nobody
wants to work that way so nobody will
you can do a local cone and create which
is a grant to create a package locally
that will end up in your cache but then
you do something I like to call cash
pollution you don't want to do that
either because you end up being unsure
what's in my cache what you want to use
is con editable which is a way to tell
conan that this package of this version
if somebody asks for the source files or
any of these folders go to this location
so let's see if I can do that
[Music]
did increase the size here at all so
let's say we want to edit include us
which is like the main library yeah
type right we'll help so I want to edit
include us and for convenience in in
class we created a file which is a
layout and I'll walk you through the
layout first here which is quite hard
the layout is layout text file and I
need to view this that's something else
otherwise I can't really understand it
so the llamo linear template this is
really complex but basically what I've
done is I have set simple equals true
which means my builder will be build
which is a relative path in comparison
to where I set the layout file and I'll
skip all this because actually can have
multiple build folders for architecture
and stuff like that and it's kind of
hard to work with and play as well I'll
tell the bin directory is I want to add
is the see make folder from where I'm
currently standing include directories
is the API from where I'm currently
standing the Lib directories I want to
expose our plugins drivers live in
platform I think all of you or at least
some of you know that scenic doesn't put
things into these folders so you also
need to modify your C make to reflect
your deployment structure when you
compile things in C make also yeah the
resource directories which is the
current directory this is a to do
because that's Konan workspaces I
haven't figured that one out yet but
it's sort of an even easier way to do
what I'm going to do now
so first I start in the the right cell
of course there so first I start hearing
include was I I make the build folder as
I said there I need a I need a built
folder right so I make a built folder
and then I do
Coenen editable add include OS version 0
1 0 at include us a let's call it stable
it's not gonna be stable but yeah and
then I want to add layout
and of course it's this folder I'm
adding no I'm not in the bill folder
that's correct
I'm not supposed to be in the build
folder because what I'm telling what I'm
telling Conan is where do you need to go
to find a common file PI where is the
mapping between the corner file PI and
location of the folders so this is a
command towards Conan internally and
most of the common commands can be
called outside of source you can specify
it all but the commands become really
complicated so now it's saying well
you're not allowed to put this in
because according to your Conan file pie
your target is 0 15 1-5 so what happened
was Conan run my semantic versioning
thing and realized that your version
should be this and you're trying to
create something else that's not ok so I
change it to match that which is
something I can do
that should be correct oh yeah now I get
an editable whatever that means right so
I can do a con an editable list and see
that yes I have an editable and the
layered files there and the path where
the editable is working on is inside
include us that looks fine what you can
do to avoid like real complications that
will arise from this is that when I now
do a a update towards the common
repository we're basically saying Conan
please give me the latest version of all
your packages I will probably get a new
package in this in which case I should
add an alias putting it to 0.99 or
something to avoid that let's see if we
can build it so go into the build folder
and we do : install dot out PR yep so I
sang to Comic Con please hand my build
folder install the entire included so
what it did was it created a generated
environment of all the include rest
dependencies that's nice and then I can
do a source activate SH basically action
exactly the same it's the same sequence
all the time the source activate SH you
run your see my code and use whatever
bindings you want inside there and to
get out your source deactivate or close
your shell and this can also be done
inside docker images so it's really nice
yeah so I can now do C make of top outs
should be able to do the most
it's now pulled in all my current
dependencies not the same list as and so
it doesn't really matter the fact is
that inside my built folder and I have
the ability to type make let's see what
happens with our previous hello world
example because that's interesting to
have a look at now so I just remove
everything in my build folder from
previously and then I Conan install yeah
just rerun the clan its if she stops up
here so if you scroll up here you see
something interesting on this line when
I redid the install it detects that
you're included stable is an editable
mode which is a very good thing to check
because otherwise you won't see your
changes don't do a new install it won't
we trade through your dependencies and
find editable so let's see what happens
now if you source activate SH and again
do the see may thought out
scroll up here you notice something
interesting it doesn't find them why is
that well in my editable I only run ran
see make I didn't ever build it so it
can't find the files there because
they're not really there so I have to of
course compile my source code which is
the entire included and that'll take
some time so while we do that I'm gonna
forward a little bit on the slides here
so I try to get rid so another part of
Conan is Conan is primarily and I I
don't think people really understand it
it's a it's convenient for developers
but it's even more convenient for CI
people and people consuming it and
DevOps and in our case for dependency
Jenkins files we use job DSL to
automatically generate all of the build
jobs to build all of our dependencies
and deploy them all that you can modify
the Conan user home to avoid cache
pollution between jobs because you want
your job to build cleanly against ya
against your repository and not against
some other build job working on the CI
no of course putting things in virtual
environments helps on this in our case
we run a Conan create package on every
single pull request so we create the
packages we run the integration tests on
them but we don't deploy them unless
they're successfully merged at that
point we upload them into the latest and
at the final we upload a stable package
if you tag a release that sort of a
convenient part of this is that
everything sort of works together and
some tips and tricks yeah we have some
time for that start with something
simple what I showed you here today is
not what I would call something simple
but it can show you where to go
yes python requires for inheriting
generic code make sure CI system package
and uploads recipes and packages use
alias if one in editable to avoid new
versions overriding your dependencies
locally always verify editable packages
when running Konan install as well as
the biggest pitfalls all of our
developers ran into that even though
they knew it so it's it's kind of
important I can't emphasize enough how
to check that we run common install
whenever you have changed the dependency
wildcards you have to add pre-release
equals true if you're less than one
point zero zero avoid pushing local
versions to package repositories that's
a no share the code not the package if
you're collaborating on unreleased
packages if you see our system support
set have it create the version numbers
automatically add the cemre commit after
the last number tag is a convenient
thing to have avoid having multiple
packages and/or recipes in the same
repository this has to go to versioning
and how we manage that avoid using too
many options you can get into an option
nightmare in between packages use unset
that's a typo there and required
settings so if the compiler doesn't
matter let's say we're combining C code
you can unset the compiler as being in
dependency you still might want to keep
it but it's up to yourself if you don't
need if you need something like a I need
the oppressor operating system are
building on when I'm building it but I
don't need it when I consume it remove
the fact that you need that operating
system and you have one package instead
of four so it's kind of important to
think about that unsetting settings is a
way of reducing the complexity
do not try using arch target it doesn't
work in Conan it's not specified there
are some documentation on it but it
doesn't work they're gonna fix it in 2.0
so for now you have to
qra around the full triple cross compile
thing run the local server to cache
packages close to the CI if it's a long
distance to your package manager you see
I'm I run into problems when building
your package that are not related to the
code or anything in it and some to do is
for include OS is to get us into 2.0 and
start using workspaces that's the things
we didn't get to do and let's just get
back to my still building got a lot of
codes bill yep so while that's building
probably some questions